les cougars de montigny le bretonneux de
retour sur le terrain du stade jean
maréchal l'équipe de baseball yvelinoise
disputé dimanche la deuxième journée des
play-off de 2e division se sont imposés
à 2 reprises face à montpellier 8 à 2
puis 11 à 6 avec trois victoires pour
une seule défaite depuis le début de
cette phase finale
les joueurs peuvent espérer remonter en
élite même s'il faudra encore l'emporter
face à boé bon-encontre et dunkerque
dans les prochaines semaines au delà des
résultats sportifs les dirigeants
souhaitent aussi s'assurer de la
viabilité de leur projet et s'assurer de
la solidité financière du club et de
l'engagement des années sont que deux
joueurs de montigny c'est la plupart
sont des joueurs de l'équipe une don de
l'année dernière et des joueurs de
l'équipe 2 qui sont maintenant donc dans
l'effectif pro mais et c'est non on a
les mêmes joueurs à l'objectif c'est ça
donc c'est pour ça l'année prochaine on
veut être sûr que tous ces joueurs de
montigny peuvent continuer à s'engager
sur une saison en élite sachant que
c'est plus c'est plus d'entraînement
c'est plus de déplacements sakho va
coûter plus d'argent au club et voir si
éventuellement se renforce et en argent
pour se renforcer
on verra mais sont les joueurs de
montigny ou désigner mon teint c'est ce
qu'on voulait